have you had kindergles before yeah
did you oh you ate them or you put them
in your trash can
[Laughter]
I've never tried eating them yeah
but they have a good than a trash bag
though
welcome back to careful boys we are very
careful boys and today we are we so we
have a bunch of
entrepreneurs in the room and one of the
biggest questions that I always like to
have for entrepreneurs is if you were to
open another business what would it be
and why
wow that's a good question a dream or
something practical that could happen
right now well I mean you're if you're
going to open the business like like you
do you have a good wine you have a good
reason why
you go first I think in the world that
I'm in if I were to open a new
restaurant business and entertainment
that's what that's what I like doing
right now
um I like the licensing type
businesses because you already have a
built-in fan base so you have a fandom
and a crowd already there so you can
already kind of
know you'll be taking care of a lot of
expenses already a lot of things like
you haven't guaranteed you have a
guaranteed income early at least okay
well if I know I'm doing this
this this crowd is guaranteed to come
here and every if I do any more work I'm
gonna bring in a whole new crowd and
that's like cherry on top so it's
licensing I love like yeah I think
licensing is great yeah I mean dude when
I visited your Hello Kitty like at the
mall
I was shocked man like we got there and
the line was long so we went to go
bathroom come back line was still long
and I was like well we might as well be
[__] in this line and when we got in
the line got longer
and it's just constantly cranking out
hell of [__] people man what do you
have a Hello Kitty restaurant or a cafe
the bakery how many there's two in Vegas
two in Vegas yeah one wow I just have
just the Vegas
it's pricey bro I got myself a the fish
thing the not the not the fish thing but
the taiyaki with the ice cream [__]
uh uh uh uh iced tea I got some I got a
couple I got a donut and it was I was
just sitting here like God damn Andy you
are a genius this [__] is so [__]
cool like because the the thing is
you're buying the art yeah you're buying
the you know your inspiring experience
yeah yeah so like you're not and you're
such a yellow kitty guys
it's more of a karaoke guy me and Hannah
were standing there eating a [__]
Hello Kitty donut and like well there's
these Kawaii ass girls like taking
selfies around us and [__] yeah and then
this mom that was in line with me she
she turns around she goes can you
believe this [__] this [__] backpack
I gotta buy it for her and I'm all like
you're the one buying it you just say no
like I know you're the one [__]
buying it I think I would have got it
back like for 75
especially if it's this big I didn't see
the power in like a like partnering up
with an established brand because it's
it's like you're right they have a
built-in audience and all this stuff and
then on the flip side you know building
a brand from scratch it's like I don't
know if I want to do that again man like
it's really I didn't realize how hard it
was because you just go based on your
passion and dream of like this is gonna
work I see all the lines like they're
they're lined up and then you just start
pumping money and and you just dump so
much money and then you just don't even
know like if it's gonna pan out and then
for me I I thought that that's just how
you do business until later I'm like oh
there's easier ways to do this [__] like
I didn't know that but there's also
strategic Partnerships right because
like let's say if I built a Hello Kitty
gym I don't think
what do you think that like
what do you think you need to like okay
this licensing and this like there's you
see something that like one plus one
equals three yeah it's like if you open
like a wrestling gym you're gonna I'm
gonna go team I'm gonna go get a
partnership with WWE because yeah people
if you're going to want to learn this
guy uses it's smart you could do that
because I was like me I'm like I'm gonna
copy what Andy does Yeah Hello Kitty gym
and then [__] go out of business like
three months not if you have pink
barbells
we were gonna build a set that was um
that was a like a cute gym so like
everything is going to be like girly
colors yeah and then we were gonna 3D
print all the weights so that you can
look like on video and pictures like
you're lifting that's everyone a good
idea that I've been trying to pitch out
let's like throw it out there that I
wanted to do like you know everyone's
trying to do Airbnb businesses and
airbnbs have slightly started declining
because
I was thinking about doing these themed
ones but you don't have to actually you
can do theme ones that don't have to
actually have the license you can use
the characters or build a certain place
those places get booked yeah if you're
when they're staying there shooting
again they experience like they're
staying there no like you just paint
Naruto like walls like bootleg in there
because it's technically your house so
you open one during Comic Con you
probably charge like like go check like
Coachella when you go RMB Airbnb during
Coachella
stay on place there is like 10 10x more
right you're paying for you can stay at
a place for one week there and it pays
for the mortgage for the entire year
your brain works better than mine Frank
yeah dude you're like
my brain's just kind of like why do I
want a bunch of Narutos on my wall yeah
yeah you'll do it during a Comic Con
week you get to charge like you can make
a copy called the comic themed Airbnb
and you can charge that week you could
charge 10 20 x more if I pay for the
whole year and everything else is just
like chill yeah even when I see your
matte black coffee collabos those are
cool like those are really well thought
out yeah Everything You Touch turns into
cold so it seems like
just just wait for my wait for my
Pokemon Planned Parenthood collabo
dude how do you know which ones to focus
on next which ones yeah because you have
a lot of Concepts going watching
it just depends on
I know just how I I guess how I figure
how much I can theme it out does it make
sense does it make sense the masses
um
how strong is the fandom like this is
fandom just like a one time it's like a
one time where they're like long term
like don't yeah
licensing
this is this is so funny if this whole
prompt was just so we could say bad ones
he can say a good one we just Jack his
idea got it thank you next week I'm like
Anime conventions coming by did you see
my Airbnb
[Laughter]
that is kind of Genius if you like have
the Airbnb next to a place that holds a
lot of conventions and you just monthly
swap the theme out yeah for whatever the
[__] that new convention what's it like
working with a licensed partner like
you're working with hello kids it's a
lot of work it's a lot of work approval
process royalty process going through
contracts approval process is probably
the toughest because yeah because they
have to say yes to everything they'll
send it back to Japan and Japan's like
oh [__] you gotta talk to people in
Japan yeah so Japan and Sanrio have to
check him out no yeah everything
do they well they work with the USA we
have to send it to the US team the US
team Sent to Japan and then Felix the
other reply back yes or no or we want to
or we want to change this it must take a
while huh do you guys get on the phone
and you're like
hello and you guys laugh for a couple
minutes like because you think you're
talking to Hello Kitty on the other side
hello can I talk to Hello Kitty
let me hear let me talk from let me talk
to the manager you know that always
awkward like you get on a business call
and you guys do like some stupid joke
and then like everyone has to like
pretend that a couple minutes of like
yeah right there so when you when you're
gonna work with like let's say a company
like uh Hello Kitty and you know there's
a whole license here you know you got to
go through like America HQ and the Japan
HQ whatever
um you know there's like holding costs
to get to launch a project like now
knowing that how long do you think you
need to plan beforehand because you know
it's gonna take it's not something I
have an idea in three months you have to
it's like a year minimum year plus you
have to usually have planned everything
else so you have to budget at least a
Year's worth of [__] rent I would say
even even longer it depends where you're
opening if you're doing something in
like California or san like in San
Francisco New York or La then it's
probably a year and a half just because
just because like permits and everything
you have to get approved already it's
like a year and a half of holding costs
you have to just sit on probably that's
why you got to work with the you know
like good enough negotiator at this
point you have like a crew right and
then like you feel in your group of
Partners you feel a specific role in
this group right like creative director
or something and then so like when you
guys roll in an idea multiple you guys
all probably have different concepts
non-stop right like coming in and then
you're partnering up with different
folks
how do you guys divvy that up or like
what is your typical week kind of look
like as your team I I stay away from the
operation I have a partner that usually
handles all the operations
um you know watch the day-to-day cost
they'll update me on on like okay this
is the monthly breakdown what happens
we're doing something here's a report
and my roles usually ideation
um
launching Concepts uh he wants to know
what ideation
what is ideation like brainstorming
ideas like it working on brainstorming
yeah okay thank you thank you for doing
that
uh brainstorming new ideas uh branding
marketing creative directing yeah
layout working on design layouts at the
store so the other partner is kind of
like execute the back end or the
accounting and the legal and the
purchasing of the property and deal
making negotiating all the and then for
you you're like like you're you're
coloring the canvas and packaging the
products as in like creating the concept
for the products and all that correct
that yeah that's my role these days yeah
what's the dumbest [__] idea you've
ever had the dumbest idea I've had yeah
a lot a lot of them tons everyone does
right tons
was one like you launched and went and
you're just like yo that was stupid that
was a mistake
my mouth closed yeah we opened this we
opened this concept but I was already
like and it just I don't have a good you
know you know those guts think you're
like man I should have done that it's a
noodle one you told us about before that
was a bad one too sorry for remembering
that but what's the one that you open
there so I opened up we opened a donut
store
called you jelly and just shaking your
head
like we know and it's done in this donut
store it we weren't making the donuts on
site because we didn't have the kitchen
to do it we weren't experts at making
donuts in the first place already
um we only knew how to make one donut
before that because we had after his ice
cream so yeah we had one donut so we
knew how to make one donut but making
tons of different Donuts that was
definitely not in our wheelhouse because
we're winging it yeah we definitely
winged it we got the special location we
decided to open that what made you guys
want to uh open a donut place we got
this we got a pretty good location that
we got offered to to do and we're like
hey this is a good location we think we
can do something cool here yeah and then
just no one was on the same page
everyone's just a different worlds of
how we wanted to execute and we want the
donut to be a circle do we really wanted
to do this you do squares so the store
we were opening a donut store that
didn't even open until 12 o'clock
[Laughter]
because nobody wanted to bake at three
in the morning and we weren't even
serving like we weren't even serving you
know your regular glaze you know
chocolate your Maple you weren't even
serving those you still want you still
want that customer yeah those are the
daily ones no Staples most people just
want some regular [__] yeah in the
beginning like it was super hyped up
lines down the block but over time pure
like
I don't want this every day I want still
want my my core my core products and
yeah and I'm like yeah what the hell
Donuts were you guys making then so I'm
like smoking like Ube Donuts some like
s'mores stuff some great like crazy
stuff so it's but it wasn't but it
wasn't made on site it wasn't like you
know we weren't experts and like hey
this is like the type of dough you want
to use there's also great great
artisanal Donuts in the area already and
we were just kind of like the hypey ones
does dough and arrow have chocolate chip
cookies or do you Shane people no I love
I think every concept I have now still
has to have
you can make all the fun stuff to bring
people you gotta have your plain white
tea you're an idiot if you don't serve
vanilla you still have to have a product
and the core product has to be excellent
you want to try some dumb ideas and see
how dumb they really are by asking them
yeah all right uh food ideas here's a
here's an idea it's like Afters
but it's meat on a cone and it's called
b4s
after you're done laughing let me know
what you think that's pretty good
actually before what about a make your
own noodle dry Noodle Bar a gym a gym
that's only you can only be in drag it's
called 24-hour fishnets that's really
good that's good you should be The
Branding Ambassador do you want to work
at line art dude see one of your ideas
guy what about like a direct to Consumer
noodle but people also use it as trash
lining
have you ever considered that
because my trash has never been
healthier than since I got kenja Bay
noodles
I've had trash for my whole life
and I've also have a chance have you had
Kinder Bay News before yeah
did you oh you ate them or you put them
in your trash can
I've never tried eating them
but they have a good feel in a trash bag
though yo dude it's like it's like wow
this is good it's very terrible good
weight like
[Laughter]
yeah you know how Bart remember Bart
like you were saying like when you have
a bunch of roommates and people like to
Crunch a bunch of [__] down nothing
crunches better than kenjamin and it
crunches at the level where it evens out
everything else yeah so you don't have
like The Oblong weird shape so like you
can crunch more it fits real nice
Definitely direct to garbage
that's what they did yeah what about an
earth like orthod oral surgeon that also
does grills
I bet they had already
in the south
oh really maybe wow I probably go
they're probably safer bed to go dude
damn yeah you're right so do you want it
do you work with the same team for all
the concepts now it's like the same like
the teams are I'm definitely getting
Tighter and Tighter over time like I'm
definitely you know like I'm not working
with as many new people just because I
know I know my team the guys I can
execute while I rather stick with them
my success rate with those guys are like
a lot higher so I was like okay I know
these guys can kill itself and in that
team is it like
um when you guys brainstorm everyone
pitches ideas from their positions point
of view yeah because some sometimes mine
I'm like sometimes I'm way too left
field and my you know my other partners
he's way more conservative so he'll be
like hey we need you need to think about
this and I'm like oh that makes sense
you know until the whole Titan muscle
abortions okay let's Planned Parenthood
stuff but we can't do this this won't
make sense in the the stream we can't
streamline this and you can't get this
across less placenta flavored things
I don't think these are selling really
well I don't know about stem cell
cookies guys the lines out the door but
I don't think we could maintain these
lines look it's a hit but I don't know
longevity wise I don't know
kind of like abortion was for a long
time so it recently got made legally
how about it how about a video streaming
platform that's nothing but childbirth
vids it's called fallopian tube hey
there's probably an audience that's
probably an audience yeah that's really
good what would be a good licensing
brand to bring to that
[Laughter]
off the market yeah it's great what
would you hey great let me let me cut
you some licenses and I want you to tell
me what you do with it
Barbie
I feel like a fun like a fun house like
a fun house like like a hotel like a
hotel like a hotel oh okay that's sweet
oh oh I gotta know what you think about
this okay the Star Wars hotel that just
went down god dude what are your
thoughts on the Star Wars Hotel what do
you mean it's like a billion dollar
failure right they're closing it where
is it no that's the one yeah we covered
it here that it opens
everybody is now closing already well
they put it and they put it in LA
instead of Orlando probably be a big
difference oh where do they build it
they build it but the price points are
so high like you want to stay there for
like a week you're paying like 12
minimums like twelve thousand dollars it
costs way too much to stay there you can
actually do that it's four grand to stay
at the hotel but yeah he's talking about
travel costs everything's awesome that's
really expensive I'm sure the
experiences insanely amazing but for how
for the everyday person like yeah but
they weren't but it's all live action
role playing in the hotel so like you're
not considering what a Star Wars fan is
mostly introverted people who don't
[__] go outside right and so now
they're going to a Star Wars hotel and
they don't even want to talk to these
[__] they're not going to appreciate
that like extra thing yeah and the cost
of even I think they had to do makeup
and makeup every day like you're putting
on a performance every day and
we're just losing a ton of money keeping
the same thing open and the performers
were there the entire time playing the
same characters for like multiple days
in a row so you have to pay for that
that was a that was a billion loss right
easily there's someone that does uh like
most people's like dream projects as
your day today what would be like your
dream project oh yeah the license
advantages no just anything like for
example like uh like a regular person
might be like oh man it'd be crazy to
own it my dream project I wanted my own
thing I want to do a theme park oh [__]
full-on that's like Disney inspires okay
what if I did like my own version of a
theme park to that caters to like my to
this generation now like oh that was
already you can't do this yeah yeah
that's crazy delete this delete this
stuff is ours it's got to pay us a
percentage it was our idea first yeah we
helped you we had that idea in a couple
JK music you could do you just gotta pay
us it's fine that would be sick to have
a theme park that was actually themed
after roller coaster type
but then it was all my own custom [__]
so if it was my own [__] I'd be pissed
everyone dies at the end of every ghost
yeah dude
you're just making death traps uh I was
making people throw up all the time it's
too tempting right I was just leaving
them in line London starve to death
I'm deleting hamburger stands all over
the [__] Park oh God what kind of
theme park would you would it be and
like and what kind of yeah like what
would be the theme it's just like Disney
has different lands I think that worked
in in their time period I guess I would
do things that work in my time I guess
my time period like the the merch stores
would probably be like very streetwear
type heavy stores uh the rides would be
you know the rides would be theme the
things I'm like I'm into like like anime
I do like a Naruto ride or a dragon like
a dragon ball team ride and it's built
the whole old world dude an anime style
like theme park would be crazy that
would do so well Planned Parenthood The
Ride
Manga theme park would go crazy Adam was
so blown up right now it's crazy yeah
you put your feet up in stirrups no I
didn't say anything cheese easy
oh you know it's a cool idea my buddy
who's from Norway he's got a bunch of
these locations it's micro climbing
you've seen those so it's like it's like
a ladder just glued to the wall how can
you get smaller than bouldering
stepladder it's in like a room this big
but they have this automated wall it's a
it's a smart smart wall that you can
program like you can design it on a pad
and then it the wall will shift to being
what you would want though like it's
more like a sideways thing than it is
like an up thing so you're just climbing
sideways well you yeah because you know
you Boulder sideways too and it is also
up but the whole wall changes to
whatever you want it to be and it's 24
hours you you have a code you go in in
case you want to climb at four in the
morning yeah you can go in at any time
and then literally you just walk in and
then you'll you'll have an area of the
wall and you go click click and then all
the points where you can grab light up
whoa yeah that's [__] crazy sick yeah
oh yeah it's like a thing only in Norway
right now but he's going to build some
out here my idea check this out only
because we're at 21 minutes and what we
mostly lose retention by now so it
doesn't matter no we will know
um so you get you do VR VR concept a
couple years ago when I was doing
trolling stuff I had a company reach out
to me called a [__] machine and
they're like they reached out to you
yeah they did they went like we want I'm
not kidding it they're like we want you
to advertise for our [__] machines
[__] awesome [__] like that and I'm
like it really just kind of jerks you
off I don't see where the [__] is
yeah
that was your big issue tough to
recommend to my audience
because your integrity is going to be
I put in my name on this product but
then I was like holy [__] now that VR is
so intense and so good because playing
my buddies VR game where he was climbing
on cliffs and [__] and look real
just do what if you did VR blow jobs
licensing porn stars
genius and now you [__] hook these
[__] up to this [__] [__] right
and these [__] will do it do anything
for money God damn dude what's happening
here and then you have them just do like
whatever they normally do on a [__] but
they're special moves and then you
program that with the [__] machine
device yeah and now it's doing exactly
what they did yeah but then the device
and you get to pick the porn star with
licensing but the device sucks so my
service will have suckers exactly and
it's got a wedding it's got a wetning
mechanism yeah
no machine and then mine's gonna be
called ha surprise because when you're
done you open it and it might be an old
man
oh it's not a machine it's that's like
putting a trash can on top of a [__]
remote control car they call it a robot
exactly that's the suck machine it's
just a box with a person inside and I
can't guarantee who's gonna be in there
dude we are real entrepreneurs and we
are we we believe in evolving you didn't
like my my VR idea from back in the day
before there was two there's one up here
one down here you you play the porn game
where you get your dick sucked the other
guy plays a popsicle race
because there's a filling in the middle
foreign
[Music]